i can't express my feelings i feel empty  it's painful it's painful to see our  house destroyed what will happen to us  now we don't have a house anymore  [Music]  we will just have to repair our house  when we receive a donation to fix it if  we receive wood and roofing then we can  repair it  as of now it's the water that we need  the most because when there's relief  goods the water is not that big it's  just about five liters so we really use  it up  we don't even have rice there's nothing  my children are crying we look for  leftovers but there was nothing we went  to bed with an empty stomach  the magnitude of the damage is really  big  it is because the one that was affected  are island provinces if you will address  those problems first a promotion problem  release logistics nightmare  [Music]  [Music]  you